hey good afternoon everyone so this is
talk I guess we'll fit in more with the
foundations of data science current
theme at Simons ah however there is
maybe a quarter of the talk that maybe
should appeal to people also in the
lower bounds lower bounds program so I'm
gonna talk about sketching algorithms
and first I wanted to find sketching
sketching is hmm essentially data
structures but where the implication and
the connotation is that you want to use
very low memory right so this is what
data structures do data structures you
give that you give the data structure
data you have some family of queries
that you want to be able to answer about
the data and now you want to create a
data structure that allows answering
these queries right
so if you notice mm-hmm I basically
wrote that down except I said sketch
instead of data structure but the
connotation when you use the word sketch
is that you want the data structure to
use very little memory so sub linear
memory that's why I wrote compress you
want to remember you don't even want to
remember the entire data set and
sometimes we'll use sketches also to
answer queries about pairs of data sets
okay so for example you have two data
sets and you want to know their
similarity or disk or distance and you
want to be able to estimate that just
given the sketches and not the actual
data sets and streaming so sketching is
data structures streaming is like
dynamic data structures okay so the idea
is the data is being updated on the fly
and you should be able to maintain your
sketch and this streaming fashion as the
data is updated which again is just
fancy word for dynamic data structures
except again where you want to use sub
linear memory and what are the benefits
so since we're using sub linear memory
of course there's less storage that's
important applications or say you want
this thing to run on say a router and
not remember every packet you ever saw
and maybe you'll run faster since if
you're using very little memory
hopefully this thing fits in cache and
also we'll there are applications of
using this industry to computation so
the idea is
you have different nodes that each have
their own data set and now you want to
compute some function of like all the
data sets together and you want to
minimize like communication right so the
idea is they only have to communicate
their sketches each node only sticking
up a sketch of it what it sees as
opposed to everything so you can get
away with less communication and so I
just want to start off with a very
simple sketching example okay this this
is very trivial but just to show you one
so suppose we see a stream of
transactions with sale prices and query
is like what are the gross sales for the
day in other words add up all the
numbers okay so obviously there's a
sketch which is just keep a running sum
okay so this is an example way or yes
you can answer the query without
actually remembering all the numbers you
saw okay so the rest of the talk I'll
give three examples that are not so
simple maybe I'll start from simplest
more sophisticated over time okay so
these are the three that I chose to talk
about in the abstract I had had I
replaced one of these two with a
different liner than at the end I
decided I wanted to make a a switch this
last one I made a switch so that this
last one appeals to people in the lower
bounds program
so let's start off with approximate
counting okay so what's that problem so
the data structure is a counter okay and
what do I mean by that so there there's
one update operation which is increment
imagine the counter stores is zero
there's query which is returned the
number returned the counter and there's
increment which is increment the counter
by one so this is my data structural
problem seems simple enough and the
simplest solution to this is to store
the counter in memory and of course if
see if the counter grows to be a K digit
number then I can use K units of memory
K bits of memory and answer this so the
question is can we use less than K units
of memory to store a K digit number okay
and the answer is no you can't store a K
digit number less than K bits but but
actually you sort of can okay and the
idea there is from this guy from from
Rob Rob Morris the father of this this
guy is yeah so who's that who's now
[Music]
that's right what's right when you okay
so what was Morris the father Morris
what was Morris's idea and the idea was
to use randomization so here's the basic
idea so I'm what I'm gonna store memory
is not the counter see but I'm gonna
store some other number X okay and I'm
gonna initialize X to 0 and whenever
someone says increment
I'm gonna flip a fair coin okay and if
the coin comes up heads then I'll
increment X if the coin comes up tails I
do nothing okay and okay so what's the
what's the idea the idea is look I only
expect to increment this X half the time
right so X will roughly be C over two so
if someone asked me what C is I'll just
report two times X okay and I so I still
basically know C but now I'm only
storing a number that's half as big so
I've saved the digit right so so this
was a horse's idea there are two
downsides okay one is I only saved one
digit by doing this and the other is
that you know if I want let's say a 99%
approximation of the answer this thing
is not going to give it if the answer is
small right there's like too much of
variance
if the answer is small okay so the
second idea is well first let me let me
show you how to save on the actually on
both but maybe I'm the first one first
how to do how to save more than just one
digit and there the idea is to be a
little more lazy about updating so
whenever the user increments does
increment I won't just whip one coin
I'll flip X coins where X is the number
that I'm storing in memory okay and I'll
increment X only of all the X coins are
heads okay otherwise I'll do nothing so
but you know when X gets bigger and
bigger it becomes more rare that I'll
that will actually increment it and you
can prove that you know the expectation
now the expectation of 2 to the X minus
1 is exactly the number that I wanted to
report so in other words X is roughly
logarithmic in C so in other words of C
is K digits long then X is about like a
digits so I've exponentially gained in
my storage okay of course this this also
has some variance so how do I get rid of
the second thing how do i improve the
the error okay and the idea is look I'm
not going to increment X with
probability point five to the X that has
the issue that I have to high variance
what I'll do is I'll increment X is
probability 0.99 to the X right if I
implemented X with probability 1 to the
X that's just the naive counter
right which has no variance it's always
correct okay so I'll increment X and 7th
probability point 9 9 to the X okay
that's close enough to one that I don't
have that much variance that's the
calculation you can do but it works out
and you can write down that you know the
expectation of this thing 100 times 1.0
1 to the X minus 1 is exactly the number
I want and this have a good variance
okay and I'm still I mean the base of
the log is now not base 2 but still see
you know the counter X is still roughly
log of C up to a constant factor so what
you can prove is that you know if I
instead of 0.99 if I make it like 1
minus epsilon or something like that I
can get away with only storing log K
plus log 1 over epsilon digits in my
memory instead of K digits and I'll know
the answer with 99% probability up to
this 1 plus Epsilon
ok so here's an example my first example
of a non-trivial streaming algorithm
that actually exponentially saved on
memory questions that's the first one
now I'll do the second one
yeah slightly more sophisticated ok so
this is the heavy-hitters problem
also I'll call it the approximate top K
problem people also call it the frequent
items problem so what's the problem so
here I know I see a stream of work items
from some universe so here words from a
dictionary okay and I want the algorithm
to process these things as they're
coming in and then when I say query it
should tell me a word that's popular
like for example the word wiki is
popular here okay so what's the formal
definition of the problem I'm given a
stream of items like words coming from
some University dink in the dictionary
and when someone says query I should
report a sub set of the universe L
containing all the frequent items okay
what does frequent mean frequent will
depend on some parameter K and I'll say
that in a stream of length L with L
words an item is K frequent if it appear
more than a 1 over K fraction of the
time so I want the list L to contain all
these items notice that any item that
satisfy that is definitely in the top K
by frequency okay but this isn't even
you know Harshal requirement and being
in the top kid you have to be really
firmly in the top K okay and I want to
use very little memory okay so the the
easy solution is maintain a histogram of
length the universe size and for each
item in the universe just keep it count
how many times did I see this and when
someone says query you go through and
you see which ones were the most popular
when you report them okay so our goal is
to use very small memory and I'm not
going to solve the problem exactly just
like with the approximate counter I
didn't tell you the counter value see
exactly I told it to you up to 1 minus
epsilon 1 plus epsilon or something so
here I'm gonna have a notion of
approximation which is well there are
sort of two notions of approximation the
first is already that I'm not exactly
solving top K I'm solving this version
where I require you to be really
frequent you know you have to be more
than a 1 over K fraction the other
notion of approximation is I allow the
list L to have false positives so you're
allowed to report some people who are
not actually frequent but you're only
allowed to have ofk of K false positives
ok but the people who are actually
frequent have to be there the list
there's another formally harder problem
which I'll call change detection which
is I had a search engine query log from
one day and then I have the search
engine query log from the next day and I
don't want to just know who's popular I
want to know who changed a lot in
popularity so for example wiki might
always be popular because people are
always googling wiki X to see the wiki
page for X but you know on that day July
16th prime had a large change in
popularity compared to the previous day
because of Amazon Prime day and
amazon.com crashing so this actually
this actually happened to me so I don't
know if anyone else tried shopping on
prime day but yeah I mean my wife and I
were waiting for this day to come we had
all these things ready
ready to buy and then I loaded
amazon.com and like this is what I saw
the page was crashing and apparently
lots of people saw this yeah did anyone
else see this right so so the change
detection problem is yeah notice that
things have changed a lot why did I say
this was a harder problem well there's a
reduction okay like if you can solve
change detection efficiently you can
also solve the normal frequent items
problem efficiently y-you can just tell
the algorithm that yesterday was the
empty stream and then give today's
stream as the tomorrow stream and the
change is just the frequency from today
right so it's formally a harder problem
there's a reduction okay so both these
problems and also many other streaming
problems you can capture in this model
called the turnstile streaming model
what is that so I imagine that there's a
high dimensional vector Z that starts as
a zero vector so for example Z is
indexed by words in the universe we're
in the dictionary and there's a sequence
of updates each update says add some
amount to some entry in Z so for example
in the frequent items problem this Delta
is always plus one whenever I see a word
I add one to its frequency in the change
detection problem yesterday maybe I'll
do plus one for everyone today I'll do
minus one so that at the end of the day
Zi is the difference between today and
yesterday okay and then at some point
someone says query and you have to
output some function of this vector Z
right so there are many different kinds
of queries you might want to support
distinct elements is like how many
distinct words were in the stream okay
so what's the support size of Z I'd the
one I just mentioned is the frequent
query which is returned this list
containing all the heavy hitters and
this list has no bounded size you could
look at many different problems and
there are many functions you might want
to compute and for a lot of them some
form of approximation and randomization
are necessary to achieve non-trivial a
small memory so you know there are
several problems like that where such a
lower bound was proven in this paper
from 96 right and what I mean by
approximation randomization is these are
going to be Monte Carlo randomized
algorithms they're only gonna succeed
with nine nine percent probability and
they're gonna output the answer up to
some notion of error so if the answer is
a number like 1% error but if the answer
is something else like a set
maybe you meet some other notion of
approximation okay so so this is what I
said was the frequent items problem I'll
say that an item is a heavy hitter if
it's frequency is more than a 1 over K
fraction of all the other frequencies
combined and I have to output a small
list that contains every K heavy hitter
and I want to say one thing before I
actually describe an algorithm which is
there's another two I'll walk through
this bullet a little slowly so that it
gets absorbed hopefully so let's look up
here I said that an item is frequent if
it's frequency is more than over 1 over
K fraction of the sum of all the
frequencies I could say you know it's
frequent if it's frequency squared is
more than a 1 over K fraction of all of
the sum of all the other frequencies
squared or instead of squared
I could put some other weight function
let's call that weight function W the
weight of its frequency is more than
cetera so if one defines a K
heavy-hitter as an index i such that the
weight so to fix a weighting function W
and let's say that it's frequent if it's
weight of its frequency is more than a 1
over K fraction of all the other
frequencies weights combined where I
don't count the top K frequencies so I
only so Z star is like the decreasing
rearrangement when you sort so I don't
count the top K what you can prove is
that this notion of being frequent
approaches the top the actual top K okay
not some approximate notion of talking
but the actual top K if your waiting
function is the P of power and you send
P to infinity okay so the note the
version that we've been talking about so
far is where P is 1 okay and then people
call that people call that the l1
heavy-hitters problem okay but you know
L infinity heavy-hitters under this
notion would actually be taught K so
maybe that's the problem I actually want
to solve ok so there's a lower bound
that's been proven it was be a reduction
from multi
already sent us joined us I won't say
what that means or prove it in this talk
but there's a theorem that says if P is
bigger than to solving this piece power
weighted version of heavy hitters
requires polynomial space and the
universe size okay so what this theorem
tells me the last thing it tells me is
the closest approximation of the actual
top k problem that I could hope to solve
and very low memory is the squared
version you know the version where I
look at the Z I squared is bigger than
single Squared's okay so because I'm
gonna say I want I wanted to make sure I
said this because the albumen I'm going
to talk about solved the p equals 2
version and if i didn't say this you
might wonder ok that seems very
arbitrary Jelani why are you focusing on
l/2 heavy hitters but there's a reason
for it the reason is it's the closest
version of top can you could hope to
solve in low memory ok questions about
this
yeah what do you inviting the ran by
sense that's yeah oh yes that's right
even if I even if I'm willing to have a
Monte Carlo randomized algorithm that
only succeeds with you know two-thirds
probability
I still need polynomial in n space okay
so known algorithms for heavy it was
there a lot of them probably more than I
fit on this slide I'm just kind of ran
out of space and there are a few that
you know I've worked on with others
I guess David's in this room and okay my
move is around he's not using Burke he's
in the City of Berkeley okay so so maybe
I'll mention what some of these do and
then I'll only focus on what in this
talk so there's this album we had from
2012 which is a deterministic not
randomized algorithm it always succeeds
for l1 heavy hitters where you can
support positive and negative updates in
the coordinates general turnstile model
and amongst amongst deterministic l1
aviators algorithms it has the
best-known memory then there's the
alamin they'll actually talk about today
which is this BP tree which is with
David and Vova and others this is a
randomized algorithm for insertion only
meaning all the deltas are +1 so it's
like it can solve the frequent items
problem but it can't solve change
detection ok but it solves l2 which is
the closest thing to actually top K you
dopa solve and then there's the expander
sketch which can handle deletions and
amongst algorithms that can handle
deletions and it has the best known
memory update I'm fairly probability etc
but it has worse space than the BP tree
and probably it needs to there's a
separation in the complexity when you
have to support change detection versus
when you don't ok
so I'll focus on this one okay so here
are some bounds so in the insertion only
case where you don't have to support
change detection okay the first album
that solved l2 heavy-hitters was the
count sketch and again I'm not writing
all previous work cuz there's a lot I'm
just maybe just writing the ones that
are closest to compare with what I want
to compare with which right now is space
so the count sketch was the first
algorithm that could do insertion only
l2 heavy-hitters and the space was K log
n words of memory okay so a word can
hold like a counter in the histogram Z
they can also hold log in bits to hold
like an index into Z then there was this
counts counts of data structure and then
there's the BP tree which is K log K so
we went from K log n - K log K and we
succeed all these succeed with nine
anchors and probability in fact the
count you know I could have written the
space in terms of the failure
probability too but this is I just chose
to focus on let's say K maybe I'll skip
yeah and so there's actually an open
problem here which is can you hope that
you can you get K words we don't know K
is the lower bound okay words is lower
bounded we don't have many upper bound
and maybe there's another table for
expander schemes let me skip that let me
focus on the BP tree and tell you how
that works okay so this insertion only
l2 heavy-hitters so the plan of attack I
should mention this yeah so I forgot to
write on the slide this plan of attack
was already there in the previous paper
the count see with with David and Bob
and others and I'll tell you kind of
I'll say I'll tell you which part we
actually you know improve to get the
better out the better space but the plan
of attack is the following so first
we're gonna make a definition we're
gonna say an index is not just a heavy
hitter but it's super heavy in this
squared sense if not only is it squared
frequency like a 1 over K fraction right
but it's squared frequency is almost
everything
if squared frequency is more than a
thousand times bigger than all the other
squared frequencies combined then I'll
say that it's super heavy
and what I'll show you is that we
there's a reduction from solving heavy
hitters in the squared sense to the
super-heavy problem if their existence
if we haven't yet item find it if
there's no super-heavy item do whatever
you want okay and then what I'll show
you is that a reduction where if you can
solve super heavy and space s you can
solve the actual problem we cared about
in space s times K log K so if we solve
super heavy and constant memory
it'll imply a K log K so that's we're
going to do and this is actually the
part where we improved over the previous
work is like showing how to solve super
heavy in constant memory that was the
thing that people didn't know how to do
so maybe I'll show you the reduction
it's a simple reduction the reduction is
the following so I'm going to
instantiate ofk but a big constant times
K buckets and each one of these buckets
will have inside of it an algorithm that
solves super-heavy and whenever I see an
item in the stream I'll first hash it to
a random bucket and then I'll process it
in that bucket and the I you know let's
let h h be the set of heavy hitters the
actual km eaters i care about
and let's say i is a heavy hitter what
you can show is that if i is a heavy
hitter
well his mass and the squared sense is a
1 over k for action of everything once
you hatch him to this bucket his mass in
this bucket is still whatever it was
before it's his mass but now he has a
lot less Maskull iding with him right so
what you can show is that in fact not
only will be heavy but he'll be super
heavy in his bucket with pretty good
probability that's not that's not a hard
calculation and then what you say is the
following
I'll actually repeat this thing so this
this thing here had like o of K buckets
and I'll repeat it Capital m times and
Capital m will be locating and what I'll
do is I'll output all the indices all
the words that reported as super heavy
in at least half the rows ok and sort of
by construction only o of K people could
possibly satisfy that just by counting
there aren't enough buckets for more to
satisfy that and anyone who actually is
heavy will satisfy this being reported
in half the rows with pretty good
probability that simple as a turn-off
bound you need down calculation okay so
this is the reduction so notice there's
log K rows and there's K columns so the
total number of buckets here is K log K
so we can implement each one in constant
memory we're done okay so the question
is how do you implement in constant
memory so that's that's the main event
so first you do some wishful thinking
you say L is the length of the stream
and ZL means the histogram Z at time L Z
T is this gram Z at time T so assume we
knew what the l2 norm of the histogram
was at the end of the stream at query
time we don't actually know the future
but pretend we did okay if we knew that
this is what we would do
we'll try to learn the identity of the
super-heavy item bit by bit right the
super-heavy item is a number between 1
and n it's log n bits I'll try to learn
those log in bits one by one and here's
how it's say first I need to learn the
zeroth bit how do I learn the zeroth bit
I'll pick a random sign vector Sigma and
I'll instantiate two counters c0 and c1
and this is what I do whenever I see I
in the stream I write I in binary so I
is 14 I write in binary I'm trying to
learn the zeroth bit so I look at the
zeroth bit the zeroth bit is a 0 so what
I'll do is I'll add Sigma 14 the random
bit court the random sign corresponding
to item 14 I'll add it to c0 okay and
now why am I doing this so let's say
that the actual heavy item sorry this
should be H sub 0 let's say that the
actual heavy item is 0 bit wasn't 0 so
what is c0 I'm going to look like c0 is
going to look like the frequency of item
H up to his random sign Sigma Sigma H
plus noise right the noise is everyone
else who also happens to end in a zero
and binary times they're random sign
and then the other bucket will also be
noise okay and super heaviness says the
super heavy guys squared mass is more
than much more than everyone else
combined so in other words the super
heavy guys frequency at the end of the
stream at the query time is like 99.9%
of the actual l 2-norm which we know
because i pretended we know the l2 norm
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna wait
until one of these counters is 10% of
the final l2 norm and once one of these
counters is 10% of the final l2 norm
I'll just declare that okay you know I'm
pretty sure so let's say this one this
one gets to be 10% of the final level to
norm I'll say at this point I'm fairly
sure that the super-heavy item ends in a
zero because this counter is so much
bigger than the other counter or this
counter got big first and then I'll try
to move on and learn the next bit and
I'll do this one by one okay so there's
a problem there but we'll get to that
yeah so yeah there's this this is
wishful thinking right pretended I know
the future and I know what the final l2
norm will be yeah okay
so you know you need to you basically
need to prove some lemma that basically
shows that this PAC picture will happen
okay so what do I mean by this picture
will happen the red curve is c0 the
yellow curve is c1 so the red curve is
where the the red curve is which one
with the bucket that can account I can
actually can need the super heavy item
and let's say 10% of l2 maybe is let's
say it's 10 okay so you need to prove a
lemma that says the dilemma basically
will say that this yellow curve will
like never ever cross 10 and the red
curve will cross 10 at some point okay
if you can prove that lemma what it
means is and this is always like 99%
probability if you can prove that lemma
what it means is you're not going to be
fooled into thinking that the you know
the last bit is the wrong bit okay and
you know that the the kind of most naive
thing you might try to do won't work
right the most naive thing is I'll prove
some kind of concentration to say that
these counter is don'ts don't blow up
and then I'll Union bound over all time
to say that not only does it not blow up
at a fixed point in time but it never
blows up at any intermediate step right
I want to prove such a thing for the
yellow curve but if you try to do this
kind of concentration plus Union bound
the Union bound totally kills you
because we're unit banging over all time
and you're basically it's not going to
work ok so I'm not doing any
calculations in front of you but that's
not going to work so you need to somehow
beat the Union bound ok and for people
who have seen this maybe you've seen
this thing we are like if you're
standing at 0 and at every step you
either walk left probably to half or
right with probability 1/2 right and
then you ask yourself you know after n
time steps where will I be
the answer is roughly Ruta in magnitude
but not only that but in any
intermediate time step you never exceed
this interval of size over done right if
you try to do it with a tail Union bound
you would get like root n times log n
but like that's gonna kill you here okay
so you need to somehow prove this kind
of
it's got like a maximal inequality
lovey's maximal inequality maybe heard
of this
maybe not it's okay that kind of it
never enter any intermediate time step
are you messed up and even this way of
thinking was already there in the
previous paper about it David and others
but they did they couldn't get the that
previous the count Steve one they
weren't able to get this constant memory
for superheavy so that get into all the
specifics but yeah so that's that's
that's that one thing I'll mention is
you can't actually afford to store this
like random sign vector right because
the random sign vector is n bits long
and I'm trying to use very little memory
so you need to somehow use some kind of
pseudo-random sign vector we use bounded
independence for wise independence and
that requires some work to show that it
works but it does and you know there
have been more applications in study of
kind of using these pseudo random you
know random variables to do to to
analyze pseudo random walks and prove
that they are useful for something but
I'm not gonna say more about that okay
so two things one is Paul asked how do
you know the future or is that right
yeah how do you know the future and the
other thing is there's another problem
there's another major problem and does
anyone see another major problem which
is I just told you I can learn one bit
of H after seeing 10 percent roughly of
its occurrences right but I'm trying to
learn log in bits but if I do this I can
only learn 10 bits okay so so I'm not
gonna say maybe you can ask me offline
if you want to know about learning the
future ok I'll say something about
learning a future because I didn't write
I didn't I didn't want to spend time on
it but I'll say something so you think
about knowing the future is you sort of
just like guess what the future will be
there's something like log n guesses you
could make you can't make all log n
guesses in parallel because that would
blow up your space by log n so what you
do is you kind of make 10 guesses in
parallel so you guessed that the final l
2-norm will either be roughly 1 or 2 or
4 or a thousand 48 or a thousand 24
sorry and then you run an algorithm in
parallel that kind of monitor is the l2
norm
and once you notice what the l2 norm is
roughly eight you're like oh my guess
that it's roughly one was wrong so what
you do is you kill that process and you
boot a new process that guess is that
it's 2048 and the point is that new
process did miss a prefix of the stream
but if that the final l2 arm really is
approximately 2048 it missed such an
insignificant prefix that it doesn't
matter okay so that's that but the other
problem you know if I can if I if it
takes ten percent of the stream to learn
one bit how can I learn log in bits so
yeah so that's a problem and the one fix
is the following so let's say I've
learned 20 bits of eight so far okay now
let's say you know I know I know that
the last 20 bits Indian one one zero one
one one zero or whatever I see a new
index I in the stream I write it in
binary if it's last twenty bits are not
consistent with the 20 bits already
learned I know that I is useless so I'll
just ignore it
I won't process it at all and I'll go
and move on to the next dream token okay
and the point is if mass was randomly
distributed around
well that basic only like one over two
to the twenty one over a million roughly
of the mass will survive this filtering
right which means that the having a
super heavy item is a even a million
times bigger than it used to be okay
which means that I can learn it even
faster okay so first I waited to see ten
percent of it occurrences to learn a bit
next time around I'll only need to see
five percent of its occurrences to learn
a bit etcetera okay
of course mass is not randomly spread
around so what I do is I pick a random
permutation and then I run the algorithm
on a randomly permute at universe and
then I unproven this has to be a
pseudo-random permutation because I
can't afford to store an actual random
permutation
okay so that's the gist of things
without full detail okay question huh
it's a again this won't run in a
streaming fashion which part won't run
is gonna go oh sorry I'm not permuting
the stream
I'm permuting the universe so like
whenever I see I I'll apply PI and then
I'll feed PI of I to my algorithm and
then at the end I'll get back some PI of
H as my answer and then I'll compute PI
inverse of that and then report H yeah I
won't permit the stream I'll commute the
things I'm seeing the stream okay so so
that's all I want to say when heavy
hitters on one last one that I promised
you might appeal to people in the other
program champion graph streaming so okay
so large streaming and there's gonna be
interactive at least right for a second
sampling in graph streaming okay
so first I'll play a little game with
you so here's a game the game is the
following you're holding a basket of
fruit okay oh think you've seen this
game I do baby here you're holding a
basket of fruit at each time step I may
do one of the following
I may insert one fruit into the basket
or I may put my hand in and grab one
fruit and remove it okay and you the
holder of this basket your net your you
see me as I insert items you see what I
insert and when I remove items you see
what I removed but never do I allow you
to look inside the basket and see what's
there
okay and when I say query you have to
report one fruit that's still in the
basket
okay right so
does the game makes sense right okay so
so we're gonna so you're gonna play and
then I'm gonna ask you so so okay so
here's what I'm gonna do first I'm gonna
insert a strawberry so now the basket
has a strawberry in it okay
now let's sort of watermelon and a grape
etc orange peach banana peach okay so I
in sort of two peaches right so there
are two peaches in the basket right now
and then I removed one so there's still
a peach okay and then I keep inserting
and removing oh they're no peaches now
can I remove the other peach and I keep
inserting and removing okay and I keep
going for a while and at some point I'm
gonna say query and I mean it's easy so
far I just remember like one thing that
you see right so okay patches right so
and then I'm gonna start removing stuff
so at some point I'm gonna say query and
you have to tell me one of the fruits
that's still inside of this basket oh
you don't worry any any second now okay
good huh strawberry yeah sorry I'm sorry
no no
no not great sorry any any other guesses
coconut now I think gradually guessing
[Music]
but I haven't heard and actually there
are actually two fruits that are still
in this basket so so like it's not just
one thing that yeah that works out here
what no nope okay so there's one plum
left in one line oh yeah so right so
right so so there's a problem so here's
the here's the a streaming problem right
so maintain Z and this turnstyle stream
I can insert things I can delete things
and when I say query report nei such
that Z is not zero
okay and this is you know I raised it as
if it were just like a game but actually
the subroutine has been used in a lot of
it's been used as a very useful
subroutine and a lot of graph streaming
problems dynamic graph streams we can
insert edges and delete edges so here
around on go ahead McGregor showed like
look at the following problem there's a
graph initially it's the empty graph on
n vertices or on B vertices I'm sorry I
can insert edges I can delete edges okay
so in other words if you look at this
turnstile streaming you know model and
as V choose to write the dimensionality
of this if this vectors and V choose to
corresponding to the edges that could
possibly be in the graph and when I say
query you have to output a spanning
forest of the graph or maybe when I say
query UV you have to tell me is there a
path between U and V or report such a
path or whatever and they showed that
you can actually output a spanning
forest and your algorithm will use V log
cubed V bits of memory and it's a
randomized algorithm with with high
probability one minus one over poly V
and yeah so kind of here
use it as a subroutine where like you're
maintaining this graph okay forget about
outputting a spanning for us right just
like someone says query just tell me any
edge that's still in this graph right
like that's already non-trivial and
that's exactly the support find problem
and there are several other works that
study not only support fine but the
sampling problem where I don't just want
something in the support of Z but I want
a random thing in the support of Z and
then the question is then random from
what distribution maybe I want something
uniform from the support or something
proportional to its weight to its
frequency or to its frequency squared or
whatever okay or in the state of the art
for these kinds of support find and
sampler problems is with probability 1
minus Delta
I'll output something in the support
it's a randomized algorithm with
probably Delta I'll I'll put junk and my
space complexity is this number of bits
log 1 over Delta times log squared n
bits of memory and it turns out that so
David would riffin Rajesh Jayram I also
can do kind of the sampling version in
the same space okay where Delta is
something like if it's not exactly but
Delta's like this statistical distance -
it's not exactly that that they get but
think of it like that for a second
so that was I think this paper was the
first to show that you could use this
thing for dynamic graph streams and
since then there are a couple exceptions
but not a whole lot kind of almost every
dynamic graph stream data structure we
have that uses very little memory sub
linear memory uses either support find
or some kind of sampler as a subroutine
and you know not just not just spanning
forest but like bipartite bipartite
incidences some graph at cetera et
cetera
it turns out that this thing is a very
useful primitive
okay so theorem is that this algorithm
that uses long run or Delta locks for
and bits of space from this paper of
Johari supplement are - is actually
optimal okay so this paper jst had an
upper bound as well okay and they had a
lower bound for constant Delta so what
this says is as long as Delta is not too
small as long as it's not exponentially
close to like whatever exponential and
end this this log of n over log where
Delta is then basically log in as long
as Delta is not too small so this is log
whatever Delta times log squared n bits
of space which matches the upper bound
and the lower bound the way we prove
this lower bound is by a reduction from
a communication problem called universal
relation and that's why I said you know
maybe I don't know maybe some people in
lower bounds thing yeah so the heart of
our kind of thing is we prove a
tightening lower bound for this problem
universal relation so this is all jargon
our Delta arrow pub okay so the next
slide will explain what that means but
what we prove is that whatever you know
this complexity of this problem is
exactly this up to a constant factor
okay I mean it turns out that this is
exactly the right answer up to a
constant factor for the full range of
parameters
okay and we also actually managed so me
and watching you so this just says that
that primitive is you know we know how
to implement that primitive optimally
the support fine primitive but maybe you
could do better for a dynamic spanning
forest right maybe the best way to solve
dynamic spanning forest doesn't use this
permanently now what we showed is that
no in fact even to use dynamic evenness
so this on glue McGregor algorithm for
dynamic spanning forest is itself
optimal you need V log cubed V and
actually watching had already proved
this thing and it without me and then
but in this paper we have another result
to which I slight slightly helped with
which was a kind of a another lower
bound for a distributed version of the
problem I'm not going to get into in
this talk but yeah so kind of what this
paper shows is that you can combine this
communication complexity result with
some kind of direct product theorem if
you don't know what that means don't
worry about it but you can prove that B
log QB is actually the right answer for
dynamic spanning forest even if you only
want to succeed with one percent
probability so even if you barely ever
succeed so what is this our Delta one
arrow pub thing so here's the model so
there's a public random string in the
sky okay and there's a function that
everyone knows it Maps so there are two
parties here let's call it we're gonna
call them Alice and Bob Alice gets an
input from X Bob gets an input from Y
you have to compute f of X Y okay so
here's the model and then this arrow
this arrow thing I use that to mean kind
of I guess one-way communication
complexity so what that means is Alice
gets the input sends a message based on
the input and based on this public
random string sends that message to Bob
now Bob knows that same public random
string pub means pub that's what this
pub means public random string Bob knows
that public random string as well as his
input Y and then has to output f of X Y
and he has to succeed with probability 1
minus Delta that's what the Delta means
okay so our Delta arrow pub is the
minimum L such that it is possible for a
scheme like this to South status scheme
like this exists a commune
patience key communication protocol okay
so that's what we show it we show that
in this model you know the optimal
complexity for this you are universal
relation thing is what I wrote so what
is universal relation before I define it
this problem originally came out of some
work on depth lower bounds first for
circuit complexity okay so the model
there was there's this function G which
maps and bits into a 0 or 1 and the
setup is that Alice receives a 0 input
for G Bob receives a Y input for G oh
sorry a 1 input for G and since x and y
mapped to different things under G X is
definitely not equal to Y so in
particular there's a bit where they
differ and the communication complexity
problem is that Alice and Bob have to
figure out which bit they different ok
and really the the theorem of this paper
was that the optimal deterministic
communication complexity for this
problem is equal to the minimum depth of
a circuit that computes G and the set up
there was a little different from the
Alice and Bob that I wrote in particular
there was no randomness there was no
public random string in the sky and it
wasn't just one message that Alice sends
they could have a conversation for Alice
sends a message the Bob responds and
they talked for a bit and then finally
they output the answer but under this
under that model of communication that
was the theorem and you know there were
some results in in circuit complexity
based on this that I'm not going to get
into and even a proposal to separate P
from NC ok then I'm also not going to
get into but it's kind of back then you
know so this thing is still open we
still haven't separated P from NCE ok
but kind of as a warmup
what they at you know what they asked
was can you at least solve this can you
at least prove something for this
universal relation problem that we made
up as like a warm-up to really solving
the the k-fold composition pure
conjecture that we hoped
okay and what is this universal relation
problem that problem is forget about
this function G and just say that Alice
and Bob are promised to get inputs x and
y that are different and since they're
different they differ in a bit
find a bit where they're different
that's the universal relation problem
and this thing is very well understood
in the deterministic communication
complexity world okay and our work gives
an optimal lower bound for the one-way
communication complexity of the public
claim model for this okay so the setup
is Alice gets a binary string X Bob gets
a binary string Y they're promised to be
different binary strings find a bit
where they're different okay and it
should be a randomized communication
protocol where Alice sends one message
so in that model we can prove the
optimal complexity yeah so and we prove
it even in the special case where we're
promised that bought the support of
Bob's input is a subset of in support of
XS so if you want to think of it this
way Alice gets a set Bob gets a subset a
strict subset find one element that's
analysis set that's not in Bob said okay
yeah so maybe this is the last slide
I'll do it before opening it up to
questions okay so I don't think I'll
have time to say how we prove it
but first I'll just show you a simple
thing which is why is this related to
the support find problem that I told you
about right support find problem the
fruit game-wise is related to the fruit
game so I claim that the space
complexity of solving the fruit game is
that with without with failure
probability Delta is at least the one
way communication complexity of solving
this universal relation problem okay why
it's gonna be via reduction okay
so suppose that I had a streaming
algorithm that solves support find I'm
going to show you that I can use that
streaming algorithm to solve universal
relation how alice is going to insert I
for every I in her set into that
algorithm then she's gonna send the
memory contents of her algorithm to Bob
as a message what's the length of her
message
it's the space complexity of the
algorithm and bits now Bob will continue
running the algorithm and he'll remove
eye for each eye in his set and then Bob
will output a dot query so what's left
in the support of Z at this point in
time it's the right answer to universal
relation right so if so good so using a
support find data structure I can
actually solve universal relation
sit-outs that's that and I think I'm
basically out of time so I have a couple
slides on how you might prove how we
prove such a thing but I'm not gonna get
into that and I always open up to
questions
[Applause]
oh okay let's see cute oh oh oh yeah
this counting okay digit number in law K
bits it is yeah it is